stop thinking small I woke up today
pissed off I got a message from a friend
of mine who I'm trying to help his
client with his marketing and I gave
everything to them on a silver platter
this is how you do it launch like this
you'll be successful you'll have clients
beating a path to your door
they'll be hustling to work with you and
instead they want to go in a different
direction that is so weak so small-time
so confusing that this client is not
going to get any results from it and it
pisses me off that pisses me off that so
many entrepreneurs don't see the
potential in themselves to think big to
have a major impact to change the world
and instead focus on these tiny little
projects with no meaning poor messaging
and that get zero results and we're so
resistant for some reason this will
change your life why are you hesitating
why are you going the weak route are you
afraid what is it I don't understand
explain it to me I came to the office I
was so pissed off and the one who why am
I so upset you know this isn't my
business why do I care so much I don't
even like the client that his is his
client that I'm trying to help the guy's
a tool I don't even like him why am I so
pissed off because I want to see my
friends business be successful I want
him to have massive success and this guy
is not just some guy off the street with
no skills trying to figure out what he's
trying to do my friend has massive
skills he's really really good at what
he does he could help a ton of people
have a major impact make a lot of money
and for some reason he keeps thinking
small I don't know I got back I wrote
him an email
I had the gladiator music going it was
it was exciting it pumped me up
we'll see what happens I don't know I
don't know maybe I should give up on it
I don't know what to do with him we'll
see but for you guys listen please stop
thinking small please you have abilities
use them have a major impact change the
world help a lot of people you can do it
stop getting cut up in these day-to-day
tiny issue is going in the wrong
direction here's how to do it one have
some big goal that motivates you why'd
you start this business it's for a
reason it was just to make a lot of
money it's not gonna happen what drives
you to get up and do something if you
have a big goal that you're Tooting
towards it's gonna motivate you to go
and think big to stop hanging around the
people who don't believe in you
if people don't like your ideas if
people say this is not possible if
people say you're never gonna make it
you dumped those guys right away if
people don't believe in your big
thinking if your client comes back and
says no I like thinking small I'm gonna
do it my way this small thinking is
great dump that guy he's never gonna be
great and 3 start building up resources
people connections that support you dump
your old friends find some new friends
who support you read a famous
entrepreneur story that inspires you
watch some of these videos build
yourself up believe in yourself and
surround yourself with tools resources
people ideas who also believe in you
stop thinking small you can do it
believe if you guys liked this video
please give it a thumbs up below
you could tell I'm upset at this wine so
I'd love to see the thumbs up give me
some support and if you have a comment
about this video or quashy for your own
business please leave in the section
below I really love seeing those come in
thanks guys we'll see you in the next
video
you